Mission Impossible rogue nation is
directed by Christopher McQuarrie and
stars Tom Cruise I'm gonna stop doing
that because I'm not that cool mi5 is
directed by Christopher McQuarrie and
starts Tom Cruise Simon Pegg Ving Rhames
Jeremy Renner Alec Baldwin Rebecca
Ferguson and is the fifth entry in the
mission impossible franchise a franchise
that I've had the privilege to grow up
watching and see evolve into greatness
and over the past month I've reviewed
all four of the previous Mission
Impossible movies in my series of m-i
reviews if you guys want to know my
opinion on the other four films all
those reviews are linked in this
description below this one is about
Ethan trying to prove the existence of
the syndicate it's this evil
organization that Benji refers to as the
anti IMF and there's even people on the
IMF like Alec Baldwin's character who
don't believe this organization exists
and Hunt and his team are out to prove
that that organization is behind a lot
of tragedies that have been occurring
I'll say this right off the bat this is
by far the best fifth film in a
franchise I've ever seen it's only real
competition is Fast Five and no the
Empire Strikes Back doesn't count
despite the fact that it's Episode five
the actual fifth Star Wars film is
Attack of the Clones
sorry I can't say the words attack of
the clones in the same sentence without
losing my mind for a brief second what
mi5 did was take the best of all of the
good Mission Impossible movies and
crammed them into a movie and it was a
blast
rogue nation recalls the first film a
lot in regards to going back to that
more tense suspense oriented espionage
it's not so much the heart pounding
nonstop action of mi3 but more a
combination of the best elements of the
first Mission Impossible and Ghost
Protocol which are my two favorite
mission films and the fact that they
were able to combine both of those to
make this movie was so much fun for me
to watch because not only are the action
scenes extremely well helmed by
McQuarrie but there's a lot of good
humor still the characters are still
very accessible and enjoyable they have
amazing chemistry with one another you
can really feel sort of this world
weariness amongst them like we've seen
this before we've been here before we're
a team we have camaraderie we're gonna
do this together you can really feel
that sense of age with these guys and
not just because they're getting older
but because you feel that these people
have been through things like this
before and they really captured that in
this movie this sense that this is a
real operating team and I'm so glad they
maintained that team element from ghost
Protocol because that is what makes
Mission Impossible a lot of fun to watch
you see all of these very important
pieces coming together to work as a
whole Rebecca Ferguson who isn't known
for much was fantastic in this movie she
had a great combination of femininity as
well as I'm gonna kill you with my pinky
finger type stuff like she was so great
in this movie it really goes without
saying now that Tom Cruise was great in
this movie he is one of the most
committed actors working today not just
in regards to the physical aspects of
his films and performing death-defying
stunts but you can just see it on his
face he is so in the zone in all of
these films and really every role that
he takes he nailed the humor and the
action as well as the little character
moments once again Simon Pegg remains a
bright spot of these films he's
hilarious and you know what Pegg is
actually a rather brilliant actor he
doesn't get enough credit for this but
if you watch Shaun of the Dead
specifically he has such a great comic
actor but he's a very good dramatic
actor as well and as I said in my
previous four reviews one of my favorite
characters and this entire franchise if
not my favorite character is Luther
stickell Ving Rhames I am so glad that
gave him more to do in this movie
because he only had one small bit and
Ghost Protocol he had that same humor
were used to seeing from his character
but he also had this defensiveness
almost a protectiveness of ethan like a
father in a way and he really sold that
element of his character and it kind of
made me like I was like ah like I said
the team element is really apparent in
this movie it also features the best
motorcycle chase I've ever seen in a
movie McQuarrie already proved that Jack
Reacher that he can really make a great
vehicular chase sequence with that car
scene probably the most thrilling scene
in all Jack Reacher in this movie a car
chase turns into a motorcycle chase and
I was gripping my seat handles it was
fantastic stuff there's also an amazing
underwater suspense sequence that was
truly honestly terrifying at times I
started to feel it right here like oh my
god my chest is caving in on me now
regards to that plane scene that we all
saw in the trailer a lot of people were
worried that we just got this amazing
sequence spoiled it's really the perfect
scene that could have put in the trailer
I'll say that it doesn't spoil anything
it was really the
best idea they had no as I said in my
previous mission impossible' reviews the
biggest issue I think this series has
had is crafting a compelling villain
Philip Seymour Hoffman is probably the
best we've had so far
ghost protocols villain was very weak
and by far the worst aspect of that
movie this villain has a lot more
motivation you can actually understand
where he's coming from he gives a very
good performance is a very chilling
character but it's still not an
incredible villain but it works for this
movie and you definitely feel the need
to put that guy in his place and that's
something that this film does very well
you really do start to be like yeah get
that guy know as I said it is more tense
like the first Mission Impossible but
there are a few moments where the pacing
drags a bit in regards to between action
scenes there's some more espionage spy
oriented conversations with gadgets and
stuff and it doesn't always hold the
same pace as Ghost Protocol did Ghost
Protocol is a far more streamlined
picture a straight-up action film filled
with humour and fun entertaining
characters it's probably the better
movie but rogue nation combines the best
of Mission Impossible and Ghost Protocol
and makes a very entertaining film I'm
gonna give Mission Impossible rogue
nation and a - guys it is tons of fun I
had a total blast with mi5 go out and
support these guys because they are
really trying to make good movie still
the fact that they've had a different
director for each one makes each one
feel fresh and different and that's been
very beneficial to this franchise so now
that my Mission Impossible series is
over my next series I'm gonna be doing
is M night Shyamalan that's right
the director who is known for various
things some good some bad his new film
the visit is coming out this September
so I'm gonna have my first review of The
Sixth Sense up very soon and I'm gonna
cover the previous M night Shyamalan
films that I haven't reviewed yet
because I obviously have reviewed some
of them already the ones I have it I'm
gonna fill in those gaps and of course
my ongoing Star Wars series will
continue with Episode three Revenge of
the Sith this August guys thank you so
much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]
[Applause]